We'll generate our key pair on our
local machine, not on our server.
Remember, you never, ever want to share
your private key with anyone else.
It should remain firmly in
your possession at all times.
For this reason,
you always generate key pairs locally.
If you were to generate
the key pair on the server,
you cannot claim that the private
key has always been private.
We'll generate our key pair using
an application called ssh-keygen.
You will first be asked to give
a file name for the key pair.
I've given this one the name
users/udacity/.ssh/linuxcourse.
This directory here is the default
directory that key pairs should exist
in, so
I advise you to keep that the same.
But you can name it what you'd like.
We'll then add a pass
phrase to our key pair,
just in case someone does
happen to get these files.
This pass phrase will prevent
them from actually using them.
Once done, you'll see that
ssh-keygen has generated two files,
linuxCourse and linuxCourse.pub.
This file, linuxCourse.pub,
is what we'll place on our server
to enable key based authentication.